right our next guest is a Bridgeton star
Golda Russellville she returns as the
Fierce and Fabulous Queen Charlotte in
the highly anticipated prequel Queen
Charlotte a Bridgeton Story on Netflix
it focuses on the young Queen's marriage
to King George III and how it ignited a
love story and a big shift in the
Bridgeton world the prequel takes place
in two timelines where present day Queen
Charlotte is in crisis after the tragic
loss of her family's on the air here's a
preview
children this is a crisis I've heard
from the Prime Minister on the topic
worse lady whistle down is talking about
it which means everyone will be talking
about it well I think you are being a
bit zealous perhaps the Greek
it is time to find husbands it is time
to trade in the Mistresses for
respectable wives get started one of you
had better produced the next ruler of
the United Kingdom or your father's line
dies with him
make me a royal baby
all right go to Russellville joins us
right now good morning how are you doing
good morning it's good to be here nice
good to have you here and you look
glorious on and off camera
this morning I try my best like the
queen that she is that's right so in
Bridgerton we often see Queen Charlotte
as this over-the-top presence do we get
to see a more human side of her in this
new series definitely you know when I
speak to fans and they come up to me and
they're very gracious and very lovely
the thing that they mention the most is
those scenes with the King you know in
Bridgeton those intimate scenes with the
King and they are few and far between
Bridgeton and you know very Glitz and
glamor it's all about the balls the tea
parties so it's really lovely now to be
able to bring to the table as you say a
more intimate look at this character a
more human look at this character we see
her as a mother we see her you know in
their first throws of becoming a wife
and dealing with George's mental health
yeah but we see she was unapologetically
herself she always had a strong Soul she
was always very feisty but you also get
to see a human side of her because as
Nate points out she's very seriously too
but do you have some favorite Queen
lines because I love the lines that she
says yeah I think the one that's gonna
pop off is Sorrows Sorrows prayers
prayers yes and then we have with the
kids scene I think it's to the
right virgins to the left or virgins the
left horse to the right I can't remember
which way round it is but yeah Shonda
has laid down some some ACE lines for
her to say definitely and we're
delivering lines like that you mentioned
mothers earlier I've read that you are
channeling some part of your own mom is
that true it is very very true
um this is an Ode to my mother I'm a
biracial person biracial actress my
mother was white my father was Guyanese
um and yeah brought up in England and
this is a kind of hats off to that
upbringing really and that kind of the
love that my mother had for England and
being dragged around manor houses at
Nehi you know and afternoon teas and all
of that kind of stuff so yeah it's
definitely channeling the love but you
also the thing about Bridgeton is
they've got great hair yeah great great
hair great costumes yes they really do
they really do I look at I'm in awe of
of what I see on the screen but for you
you had a great hair moment while you're
working on this particular show yeah but
it never happened to you before it was a
great moment and a very moving moment as
well it was the first time that a a
designer of hair and makeup had
come to me and said we're going to tease
out the front of your hair
and we're going to incorporate it into a
wig that is made out of dreadlocks a wig
that has textured hair a wig that has
plaits and braids and to have that
spoken to you know an actress of color
means you are seen I was gonna say what
did that mean to you yeah I was I was
seen as a biracial person you'd never
felt that way before never never never
and you know and I've been in this
career quite a long time but also as
well I think it's important to say that
the character
was going to be seen yeah you know we
have to get these stories out for our
community but to celebrate who that
representation and the representation
matters race plays a big role though in
this in this Queen Charlotte because
they have a scene where the young Queen
is coming to meet her in-laws for the
first time and they're saying she's a
little Browner than I thought they even
touch her at one point like is it going
to rub off or something what did you
think about that when I first read that
I was reading with my partner
it was a quite a shocking moment and I
did question whether we could do that
whether we could do that yeah it was it
was quite scary you know and because
that's that's what we need to question
isn't it going forward and you know my
partner was like hell yeah
and I love that Shonda is the person to
do that yes you know she is all about
representation inclusivity and I think
we as artists as people in the media
have a platform that we can celebrate
those stories and we can talk about
those stories in a way that maybe takes
the pressure off a little bit that's
right to help people lean in to help
people be entertained and then go out
into the wider world and discuss what
they see sometimes you have to have
uncomfortable conversations
very welcome thanks for having me 24
karat gold of Russian village
Bridgeton story premieres globally on
Netflix today 24 Karat I like it I like
it